do your kids have a good teacher
how do you know
maybe the teacher next door is better
maybe there's a better teacher in
another state maybe there's a world's
best teacher or several
wouldn't it be great if your kids could
have that teacher
well today
yes you can
yay i got it
these kids are this excited about a math
website it's amazing negative four minus
four and we are
done it taught me a lot of things
five years ago hedge fund analyst sal
khan created videos like these to tutor
his cousin that worked out well so then
i started tutoring her brothers and more
cousins and all the rest and i had to do
the same lecture over and over again so
i had a friend who who said hey sal why
don't you put some of your lectures on
youtube i decided to give it a shot
welcome to the presentation on basic
edition soon
thousands watched his lectures i started
getting letters from people and comments
on youtube and
they are they're not like hey i think
this kind of might have helped on my
math exam they're like
i gotta i failed calculus the first time
i started watching the videos now i'm
acing the class the youtube numbers kept
rising and he got letters from the
middle east africa what's all khan has
done is amazing
now khan is funded by bill gates and he
offers web lectures on everything from
history to economics to computer science
his videos are viewed millions of times
not only is it reaching millions of
students right now but even if god
forbid i got hit by a bus when i walk
outside it'll still be able to reach
millions and maybe eventually billions
of students you just happen to be
good at teaching well i'll take that as
a
compliment
it is a compliment he's a great teacher
i hope that helps see you in the next
video it's really helping us learn a lot
more it's exciting that he gets kids so
excited about math
in most parts of life things have gotten
much better cars computers cell phones
education not so much right you know you
rewind i don't know 80 or 90 or 100
years and
you would have the local band that you
know if if you had a party that was the
only gig in depth each village might
have a storyteller exactly exactly but
then once you have mass media coming out
then people say wait why don't we take
the best musician the best actor uh the
best storyteller in whatever way and
record it and put it out on
radio put it out on on records or you
know whatever and i think
in theory that could have happened with
education before but it hasn't even for
basic math multiplication tables i
thought they'd be using video games yeah
why not
there's a huge bureaucracy most of which
wants to say no to change the system the
blob people it's the blob and it is and
i think what's
fun from our point of view is that we
are able to reach students
outside of the blob this california
school district started using khan's
videos in fifth grade classrooms the
teachers were skeptical but now they're
impressed at what it does for the kids
they're happy to walk in the door every
morning they're excited about math it
isn't oh we're doing math it's like oh
my gosh we have math this morning that's
great she's just like learning new
things we assume that
most people on their own don't want to
do don't want to learn or don't want to
get engaged in mathematics and yeah but
i think they're just frustrated because
they're
most of them are in classrooms that are
not catering to them at first teachers
worried that the online instruction
could replace them but i think it's so
wrong as my teachers would tell you they
have taught more math than they've ever
taught before now teachers can tutor
kids one-on-one i noticed you were
having some issues
with
fractions
and because kids can go at their own
pace i've got students who are still
working on easy multiplication and then
i've got students who are working in
high school math some kids enjoy khan's
lessons so much they study at home some
of them are doing two and three hours a
night at home when i'm asking for 15
minutes when i'm at home and i have some
time i just log on and it's way more fun
to do math so finally after all these
years of kids being bored in school and
not learning math that's over
i i think it might be hope so if it
happens it will be thanks to those
online classes or the charter schools or
other experiments that break out of the
union-dominated government monopoly
let a thousand flowers bloom
it's competition that's given us better
medicine transportation technology
everything
don't our kids deserve that too
that's our show